ok les chéris je coupe
ma championne tu veux cette carte
tu l'asses sont bien c'est parti c'est
le quartier c'est parti c'est un 5e tu
prends laquelle tu veux savoir celle-là
je suis derrière toi alors je vais dire
celle que tu as manqué tu as manqué à
toi bien joué ou bien joué bien joué
dans mon cas attends
qui a gagné entre Géraldine et Daniel
qui a gagné qui va s'en prendre plein la
gueule pour pas
qui qui va prendre c'est un 7 c'est
Daniel
le
[Applaudissements]
verra directement alors
non non
c'est lui
qui attendait
ma chérie
sur facebook
attention
ça va être une bataille à trois
maintenant
sachez que on va jouer pour un ice
bucket 2 seront sauvés Anaïs bucket vous
voyez il y a le saut là-bas je vais
appeler je vais appeler je vais appeler
regarde pas du tout non je vous fuis
tu ne seras pas appelé je vais appeler
Valérie Benaim allez Valou je vais
appeler Kelly Vedovelli
et je vais appeler
je vais appeler je vais appeler j'ai
envie de le faire
Guillaume
attention
3 puisque tu es un homme encore une fois
tic-tac attention la barbichette
attention la barbichette merci c'est
parti on y va on y va c'est parti les
chéris première carte c'est Valérie
Bénaïm je rappelle je rappelle les
chéris je rappelle les chéris je
rappelle que ça va jouer en deux mois
c'est parti déjà il y aura une première
manche ou chacun va prendre une carte
c'est parti la carte la plus faible est
éliminée la carte plus faible 4 la plus
forte gagne les deux quartiers plus
forte l'autre bien sûr est éliminé il va
jouer un deuxième tour après il y aura
un deuxième tour et puis après il y aura
les deux perdants ensemble vous
inquiétez pas c'est que de la bonne
est-ce que tu veux cette carte tu veux
cette carte tu veux cette carte
vous passez celle-là c'est parti et donc
vous êtes le plus gros donc vous êtes
qualifié merci ok c'est bon attention
c'est entre elle et toi attention c'est
entre dernier et toi c'est parti
Guillaume j'entends tu peux aller te
laver les pieds c'est bon merci c'est
parti c'est parti la carte merci c'est
parti attention maintenant c'est la plus
petite carte bien sûr qu'il va faire la
Xbox et c'est parti on y va on y va on y
va on y va c'est parti les chiens on y
va est-ce que tu veux ça là est-ce que
tu veux celle-là vas-y ouais tu veux ça
là
c'est ainsi
la dernière du dessous
la dernière du dessous attention
c'est indice c'est Valérie Benaim merci
Karim beno Méli vous êtes qualifier
merci bucket challenge c'est Valérie
attention
comme les Tunisiens tu sais qui se
baignent tu vois ou pas tu te moques
comme ça tu vois attends attends attends
tu es sûr que tu es prête sinon je
prends ça les gars mettez-lui une petite
serviette là pour le micro ça c'est
compliqué tu sers à quoi là merci ouais
bien sûr c'est très dur à faire une
connerie
attention chérie attention
[Applaudissements]
bravo
les chéris bravo Valérie bravo chérie le
sol était incroyable
toi aussi Daniel tu es belle avec les
cheveux
calme-toi quand même et ça dégoûte tout
le monde euh les chéris attention on va
jouer maintenant pour piquer une tête
dans la piscine je le rappelle les
abrutis je connais y aller pas on
plongeant bien entendu surtout pour
l'aîné proémi pour éminent voilà n'allez
pas là-bas vous allez vous casser nez
bêtement donc vous allez gentiment et je
veux voir baigner baigner comme un
beignet d'accord
ça va être un duel
un duel au sommet
je vais demander
je vais demander à Gilles Verdez
également
du patron il va falloir il va falloir
aller se baigner dans la piscine il va
falloir aller se baigner dans la piscine
je rappelle ce baigner dans la piscine
c'est parti et à la fin il y aura le
dernier challenge regardez regardez vous
voyez cette ce tractopelle idiot il y a
de l'eau donc vous allez vous asseoir et
là bien entendu
tout le monde juin c'est un gâteau même
moi et la plus petite carte se mettra
là-bas et bien entendu on prend un peu
la gueule pour pas ok bon les chéris
attention c'est parti pour l'instant
c'est une c'est une baignade une
baignade en cheminement
attention c'est parti les gars j'ai
coupé j'ai coupé c'est moi qui décide
j'en ai rien à j'ai pas trop
rester 2h tu veux ça là la quatrième
carte s'il vous plaît chef la quatrième
quart s'il vous plaît c'est bien sûr la
plus petite qui a se baigner la petite
cage qui dit 15 minutes on est je
vérifie quand même rien parce que j'ai
des horaires tristes il est 18h52 on est
en direct merci comment ça va les gars
merci c'est parti c'est parti on y va on
y va on y va on y va c'est parti tu veux
la 4e 8 la 4e c'est un As tu es sauvé
c'est un là s'il te plaît si c'est moi
qui fait les règles merci gros de
mentalité la numéro 2 attention c'est
parti il veut la numéro 2
ça casse pas déjà fait en place
37e mais tu me fais chier et moi
laquelle celle-ci
c'est un huit tu passes c'est bon
attention tu prends laquelle Mathieu va
me donner celle qui est juste en dessous
la première
tiens la deuxième en fait vraiment tu es
sauvé c'est un roi c'est
tu barbotes ok tu marques merde
[Applaudissements]
ça fait mes parents on commence
attention les chiottes attention les
chéris c'est parti les chéris on va y
aller s'il vous plaît maintenant casse
la nuit tu peux venir me rejoindre parce
que c'est pas parce que tu as fait ça
que tu vas pas voir
tu es
par exemple
on a perdu une première fois on peut les
chéris
on va tous prendre une carte non
attendez c'est moi qui veut dire chacun
votre tour là la plus petite carte ira
se placer sous le tractopelle qui est en
train de se mettre en marche
c'est du chocolat les chéris je vais
vous appeler un par un pour venir
chercher votre carte
petit garçon tout le monde tout le monde
attention c'est parti je vais demander
à Raymond devenir chercher sa carte
comme par hasard
[Applaudissements]
attention
il est foutu
pour me demander quand vous voulez que
je prenne ma carte également
il y en a partout
la première vidéo je prends la première
qui me vient à l'esprit celle-là ou
celle-là voilà d'accord vous gagnez
merci
merci Monsieur
moi je suis sauvé donc je peux
maintenant
ma clé jamais deux amis j'ai les Valérie
sachez maintenant c'est une
bataille entre Valérie et Gilles et
Valérie venez me rejoindre je te donne
ma chérie gardez vos cartes vos cartes
c'est là je ne veux plus jamais les
revoir de toute ma vie
qui va se faire traiter
ça donne-moi ça il va me mettre un truc
sur la gueule
vous pouvez me consulter vous pouvez
prendre une carte une carte chacun notre
représentant si bien sûr bien sûr vous
pouvez mélanger je me tourne vous
mélangez les cartes tu peux mélanger
donc là je crois la carte tu prends ma
carte
montre-la ma carte je vous la montre moi
je prends toujours la première c'est un
porte chance il y a un sac à dos
de notre amitié vous avez passé une
bonne journée
c'est extraordinaire ce qui se passe ce
soir c'est pas ça
c'est incroyable
je pense que tu fais exil laquelle tu
veux la première toujours chef je
commence à me dire
quoi
déshonneur c'est à 3 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le dragon le dragon le dragon on va
l'équiper s'il vous plaît c'est quoi
sachez que c'est pas ça chez vous
tu as perdu tu as perdu donc carrément
démarre un moteur
attendez vas-y assieds-toi il a peur il
a peur j'ai mal qu'on fasse tout ça des
comptes bien entendu et chez vous aussi
vous allez faire un décompte les chéris
les chéris Gilles est-ce que ça va mon
chéri pourquoi ça va pas ok
non vous avez votre regard de quand je
sautais ou j'ai peur un dernier mot à
dire à Fatou à ta famille
enfin tout je t'aime je prends un risque
insensé sans doute mais j'ai perdu je
suis un looser Fatou je suis un
looser je comprends pas dit des trucs on
savait pas
je prends la première carte ok Michel ok
mon chéri dis-moi
tu es prêt moi je suis prêt ouais je
sais pas quoi mais je suis prêt
je vais demander est-ce qu'on peut
récupérer le micro parce que je veux pas
qu'on merci
Fatou je t'aime je serai toujours là
pour toi Fatou je t'aime j'arrive à tout
j'arrive
Fatou est toujours de ce monde
[Rires]
j'arrive et là après les dernières
informations que j'ai pas tout toujours
vivant
fou ça c'est parti on va faire tous un
décompte
c'est des gravats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans quelle émission
dans une autre émission il faut une
répète
non ils sont arrivés
que c'est la bonne humeur
le gars le gars du feras je connais tu
es sûr que c'est la bonne distance
[Rires]
et je vous jure que tout à l'heure je
l'ai vu et je me disais c'est vrai
je me suis dit c'est un bras ça va
s'allonger aussi mais j'avais pas prévu
ça brille c'est plus peur que de mal
hein exactement exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]